MINUTES.
FIRST IT'S TIME FOR OUR BREAKING
NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
YOU ARE WATCHING OUR MONOLOGUE,
THINK ABOUT THESE THREE SIMPLE
QUESTIONS.
DO WE AS A CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC, DO WE HAVE THE RIGHT
TO SOVEREIGNTY?
DO YOU BELIEVE IN BORDERS?
DO YOU BELIEVE WE HAVE A RIGHT
TO PROTECT THOSE BORDERS,
PROTECT OUR SOVEREIGNTY.
FOR WEEKS WE'VE BEEN WARNING
ABOUT THE LOOMING CRISIS ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, NOW AT LEAST
5,000 MIGRANTS HAVE ALREADY
ARRIVED IN THE MEXICAN BORDER
CITY OF TIJUANA WITH THOUSANDS
MORE STILL ON THE WAY.
THEY ARE ALL DEMANDING ENTRY
INTO THE U.S., MOST UNDER AN
ASYLUM DESIGNATION.
BUT OVER THE WEEKEND WE SAW
SEVERAL HUNDREDS OF THESE
SO-CALLED ASYLUM-SEEKERS, LOOK
AT WHAT THEY'RE DOING, THEY ARE
RUSHING THE U.S. BORDER.
THEY ARE HURLING ROCKS, BOTTLES,
OTHER OBJECTS OVER THE FENCING.
THREE BORDER PATROL OFFICERS
WERE STRUCK.
BROKEN WINDOWS, DAMAGED
VEHICLES, IN ORDER TO PROTECT
THE BORDER IN THEMSELVES, U.S.
BORDER PATROL AGENTS FIRED
NONLETHAL TEARGAS TO DISPERSE
THE MOB OF MIGRANTS TRYING TO
BREAK ACROSS BY FORCE.
EARLIER TODAY, BORDER PATROL
CHIEF DESCRIBED THIS TENSE AND
SCARY SITUATION, TAKE A LOOK.
>> OUR AGENTS WERE BEING
ASSAULTED, LARGE GROUP RUSHED
THE AREA AND THERE WERE THROWING
ROCKS AND BOTTLES AT MY MEN AND
WOMEN, PUTTING THEM IN HARM'S
WAY AS WELL AS OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE CARAVAN.
WE NEEDED TO DISPERSE THE GROUP
AND WITH THAT ASSAULTIVE NATURE
IT WAS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
DISPERSE THEM FROM THE AREA.
>> SO IT WASN'T BECAUSE THEY
SEEM TO BE RUNNING TOWARDS THE
UNITED STATES, IT WAS BECAUSE
THEY WERE HITTING YOUR BORDER
PATROL WITH ROCKS AND BOTTLES?
>> YES, SIR, THEY WERE.
>> Sean: MEANWHILE OVER AT
FAKE NEWS CNN, RODNEY SCOTT HAD
THIS TO SAY ABOUT THOSE WHO RUSH
THE BORDER, TAKE A LOOK.
>> EXPLAINED THE DECISION TO USE
THE TEARGAS, BECAUSE THAT IS ONE
QUESTION I THINK PEOPLE HAD THIS
MORNING.
>> ONE OF OUR PRIMARY MISSIONS
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP THE
BORDER SAFE AND SECURE.
I KIND OF CHALLENGE THAT THIS
WAS A PEACEFUL PROTEST OR THAT
THE MAJORITY OF THESE PEOPLE
WERE CLAIMING ASYLUM.
WE ENDED UP MAKING ABOUT 40 TO
ARREST, ONLY EIGHT OF THOSE WERE
FEMALES AND THERE WERE ONLY A
FEW CHILDREN INVOLVED.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WE
ARE DEALING WITH HERE WHERE
ADULT MALES.
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE SAW THE FIRST
WAVE OF THE CARAVAN THAT CAME UP
ABOUT A WEEK OR SO AGO, THE
GROUP IMMEDIATELY STARTED
THROWING ROCKS AND DEBRIS AT OUR
AGENTS, TAUNTING THE AGENTS.
ONCE OUR AGENTS WERE ASSAULTED
AND THE NUMBERS STARTED GROWING,
WE HAD TWO OR THREE AGENTS AT A
TIME INITIALLY FACING HUNDREDS
OF PEOPLE AT A TIME.
THEY DEPLOYED TEARGAS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND TO PROTECT THE
BORDER.
IF THEY WERE TRULY
ASYLUM-SEEKERS THEY WOULD'VE
JUST WALKED UP WITH THEIR HANDS
UP AND SURRENDERED, AND THAT DID
NOT TAKE PLACE.
>> Sean: JUST A FEW MOMENTS
AGO ON "THE STORY," CHIEF SCOTT
ALSO HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT THE
MIGRANTS, TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE TOOK THIS CARAVAN VERY
SERIOUS FROM DAY ONE, IT'S LIKE
NO CARAVAN WE'VE EVER SEEN
BEFORE.
YOU'VE HEARD REPORTS THAT
CARAVANS HAPPEN ALL THE TIME.
THAT'S TRUE, BUT NOT CARAVANS
THAT HAVE A PROPENSITY FOR THIS
TYPE OF VIOLENCE AND NOT THESE
MASSIVE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE.
WE WATCHED AS THEY CAME UP
THROUGH MEXICO, THE VIOLENCE
THAT THEY WERE SUBJECTING THE
MEXICAN POLICE AND THE MILITARY
TOO.
WE PREPARED ACCORDINGLY.
>> Sean: MORE VIOLENCE THAN
PREVIOUS CARAVANS.
THIS IS A SERIOUS SITUATION.
WE DON'T WANT ANYBODY TO GET
HURT AND WE DO KNOW A LOT ABOUT
THOSE NOW TRYING TO CROSS OUR
BORDER.
EVEN ON CONSPIRACY TB MSNBC, A
REPORTER ACTUALLY STUMBLED UPON
THE TRUTH AND TOLD IT.
THE MAJORITY OF MIGRANTS AT THE
BORDER, THEY ARE NOT
ASYLUM-SEEKERS, THEY ARE MOSTLY
MEN LOOKING FOR A BETTER LIFE
AND I BELIEVE THAT PROBABLY
ABOUT 99% OF THEM, BUT WE WILL
TELL YOU MORE IN A SECOND, TAKE
A LOOK.
>> SHE SAYS SHE IS HOPING THEY
GIVE HER A CHANCE TO WORK.
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
THIS FAMILY, THIS FAMILY HASN'T
REALLY TALKED ABOUT ASYLUM
PER SE, THEY ARE SAYING THEY
DON'T EVEN WANT TO COME TO THE
UNITED STATES AND DEFINITELY
THEY ARE GOING TO BE ASKING FOR
PERMISSION TO WORK FOR THREE TO
FOUR YEARS.
FROM WHAT WE'VE SEEN, THE
MAJORITY ARE ACTUALLY MEN AND
SOME OF THESE MEN HAVE NOT
ARTICULATED THAT NEED FOR
ASYLUM.
INSTEAD THEY HAVE TALKED ABOUT
GOING TO THE UNITED STATES FOR A
BETTER LIFE AND TO FIND WORK.
>> Sean: BORDER SECURITY
SHOULD NOT BE A PARTISAN ISSUE.
MOST INDIVIDUALS WHO TRY TO
INTEGRATE INTO THE U.S., THEY
COME FROM COUNTRIES, NO
OPPORTUNITIES, POVERTY.
THEY WANT WHAT WE OFTEN TAKE FOR
GRANTED, BUT THAT'S NOT ALWAYS
THE CASE.
THAT PEOPLE CONSTANTLY TRYING TO
GAIN ACCESS INTO OUR COUNTRY.
I'VE BEEN DOWN TO THE BORDER
MORE THAN ANYONE ELSE THAT I
KNOW WHEN THE MEDIA, ABOUT 13
TIMES.
I'VE WITNESSED ILLICIT DRUG
SMUGGLING OPERATIONS, DRUG
WAREHOUSES, HUMAN TRAFFICKING,
VIOLENT GANG MEMBERS ARRESTED.
I'VE SAT THROUGH A BRIEFING WITH
THEN GOVERNOR RICK PERRY SHOWED
WHAT 642,000 CRIMES COMMITTED
AGAINST TEXANS ALONE AT THE
HANDS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN
JUST A SEVEN YEAR PERIOD.
THIS WEEK THE SUSPECTED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS CHARGED WITH KILLING
A TEXAS TEACHER DURING A
HIT-AND-RUN INCIDENT AND
ACCORDING TO THE DHS THEY HAVE
IDENTIFIED, ALONG WITH MEXICAN
OFFICIALS, OVER 500 CRIMINALS
THAT HAVE INFILTRATED THE
MIGRANT CARAVAN.
BAD PEOPLE MOVING AMONG THOSE
THAT WANT OPPORTUNITY.
THOSE WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS
ALWAYS ACTIVELY TRYING TO GET
INTO THE U.S.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE SAFETY
AND SECURITY OF EVERYONE LIVING
HERE, WE'VE GOT TO PROTECT OUR
BORDERS.
IF WE HAD A SECURE WALL RIGHT
NOW, NOBODY WOULD BE IN HARM'S
WAY.
IN LIEU OF A ROBUST BORDER WALL,
THIS COUNTRY WILL ALWAYS BE
VULNERABLE.
IF YOU SAW IT THIS WEEKEND, LOOK
AT THE VIDEOS, LOOK AT THE
PICTURES.
AGENTS FORCED TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES AGAINST HUNDREDS OF
SO-CALLED ASYLUM-SEEKERS
ATTEMPTING TO BREAK INTO THE
UNITED STATES BY FORCE.
BY THE WAY, THOSE WHO SEEK
ASYLUM DON'T GENERALLY ASSAULT
U.S. BORDER PATROL OFFICERS.
AND THERE ARE ABOUT 10,000 OR UP
TO 10,000 MORE PEOPLE COMING.
BUT NOT ACCORDING TO THE LEFT.
LIBERALS, DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA
NOW WAGING A FULL-SCALE SMEAR
CAMPAIGN AGAINST THOSE DEFENDING
OUR RULE OF LAW, OUR COUNTRY.
ONE DEMOCRATIC SENATOR ACTUALLY
TWEETED, THEN DELETED, A
SUGGESTION THAT THE BORDER
PATROL ENGAGE IN A CHEMICAL
WEAPONS ATTACK.
WHY?
BY FIRING TEARGAS?
RIHANNA CALLED THE BORDER
PATROL'S ACTIONS "TERRORISM" AND
THEN THERE'S THAT DEMOCRATIC, I
GUESS, ROCK STAR, ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ TWEETING "ASKING
TO BE CONSIDERED A REFUGEE AND A
TO BE CONSIDERED A REFUGEE AND P
TO BE CONSIDERED A REFUGEE AND Y
TO BE CONSIDERED A REFUGEE AND N
TO BE CONSIDERED A REFUGEE AND G
FOR STATUS ISN'T A CRIME.
IT WASN'T FOR JEWISH FAMILIES IN
GERMANY, IT WASN'T FOR TARGETED
FAMILIES FLEEING RWANDA.
IT WASN'T FOR COMMUNITIES
FLEEING WAR-TORN SYRIA.
BY THE WAY, LAST TIME I CHECKED
THROWING ROCKS AND BOTTLES AT
LAW ENFORCEMENT GENERALLY
DOESN'T COUNT AS AN APPLICATION
FOR REFUGEE STATUS.
IN ANY COMPARISON, BY THE WAY,
AND LINDSEY GRAHAM POINTED OUT
IN A TWEET TODAY OF THE
HOLOCAUST TO MODERN-DAY
CENTRAL AMERICA DOES AN EXTREME
DISSERVICE TO THOSE WHO SUFFER
AND WERE MURDERED WITH
UNBELIEVABLE EVIL UNDER NAZI
GERMANY.
THE DEMONIZATION OF THE BORDER
PATROL, TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUED ALL OVER TV.
PREDICTABLE BUT SAD, TAKE A LOO
LOOK.
>> WE HAVE PLENTY IN THIS
COUNTRY, PLENTY TO SHARE, PLENTY
FOR EVERYBODY AND I THINK WE
NEED TO REMEMBER THAT THE REASON
WE ARE GREAT IS BECAUSE OF THIS
MELTING POT OF IMMIGRANTS.
>> THERE HAS GOT TO BE A
PRAGMATIC AND COMPASSIONATE
ENGINEER THAT DOES NOT INVOLVE
TEARGAS AND CHILDREN.
THAT IS NOT WHAT AMERICA IS.
>> USING TEARGAS IN THIS
SITUATION DOES NOT SEEM
JUSTIFIED.
WE ARE INVESTIGATING THE FACTS
ON THE GROUND BUT A HISTORY OF
USING UNNECESSARY FORCE.
>> HERE WE LOOK AT CHILDREN
BEING SUBJECTED TO TEARGAS, THAT
THE UNITED STATES CAUSING THAT.
THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
>> THE WRONG SIDE OF HISTORY ON
THE WRONG SIDE OF DECENCY.
>> THE MILITARY DOES HAVE A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF INDEPENDENCE.
THERE ARE MORE LINES THAT THEY
WILL OR WON'T CROSS.
>> Sean: SO WHAT SHOULD BORDER
PATROL DO WHEN THEY ARE BEING
HIT WITH ROCKS AND BOTTLES AND
OTHER THINGS?
WHAT YOU JUST SAW IS PURE
POLITICS IN MOTION.
PEOPLE LITERALLY LYING TO YOU.
IF YOU SAW THE VIDEO, WE WILL
SHOW IT AGAIN TONIGHT.
IN 2013, INTERESTINGLY DURING
THE HEIGHT OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, GUESS WHAT?
BORDER PATROL AGENTS DID THE
EXACT SAME THING.
"THEY USED PEPPER SPRAY TO FEND
OFF A GROUP OF 100 MIGRANTS WHO
ATTEMPTED TO RUSH THE SAME EXACT
PORT OF ENTRY."
SO WHERE IS THE MAINSTREAM
LEFT-WING MEDIA OUTREACH THEN?
WHERE WERE DEMOCRATS TWEETING
DRAMATIC TWEETS ACCUSING THE
PRESIDENT OF ALL SORTS OF
THINGS?
OF COURSE THAT WAS THEN, THIS IS
NOW AND WHILE THE SECURITY
THREATS OF UNVENTED IMMIGRATION
REMAIN THE SAME, THE POLITICS OF
THE LEFT HAVE CHANGED AND
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY.
WE'VE SHOWN ME THE VIDEO OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
THEY NOW BELIEVE IT'S
POLITICALLY EXPEDIENT TO PUSH
FOR OPEN BORDERS, UNFETTERED
IMMIGRATION, SANCTUARY CITIES,
THE END OF ICE AND THAT'S WHAT
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL HOPEFUL
KAMALA HARRIS ACTUALLY COMPARED,
THERE'S A PERCEPTION OUT THERE,
ISN'T THERE, WITH ICE AND THE
KKK.
NOW THE LEFT IS TRYING TO SCORE
POLITICAL POINTS OVER WHAT IS
NOW AN ACTUAL REAL CRISIS.
OUR BORDER PATROL AGENTS DESERVE
OUR PROTECTION.
THE RULE OF LAW NEEDS TO BE
ADHERED TO.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
THE 500 CRIMINALS THAT MEXICO
AND THE U.S. HAVE IDENTIFIED AS
HAVING INFILTRATED THE CARAVAN.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
EXTREME SECURITY RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THEY SURE DON'T CARE THAT EACH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT ACCORDING TO
THE STUDY HELD THREE WEEKS AGO
THAT SUCCESSFULLY ENTERS THE
COUNTRY COST YOU THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYER AROUND $70,000 PER
YEAR.
THE LEFT ONLY CARES ABOUT
WINNING, NO MATTER THE COST, NO
MATTER THE DAMAGE, NO MATTER THE
RISK.
THEY ARE NOT GETTING ROCKS
HURLED AT THEM, OR BOTTLES
HURLED AT THEM, CLEARLY
POLITICAL.
SADLY THIS IS JUST THE
BEGINNING.
LET ME MAKE A PREDICTION.
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS, THE
LEFT'S SOLE FOCUS WILL BE
DESTROYED TRUMP, FOR YEARS I
HAVE WARNED YOU, WHAT, ABOUT THE
FIVE FORCES OUT TO DESTROY THIS
PRESIDENT.
WE HAD TWO YEARS OF NONSTOP
ATTEMPTS AT DELEGITIMIZING A
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT.
THE DEMOCRATS WON, THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THE
DEEP STATE, THREE.
WEAK REPUBLICANS FOUR, THEY WANT
TO BE PROVEN RIGHT.
SO MARK MY WORDS.
AS WE NOW HAD INTO JANUARY, THEY
HATE TRUMP HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, WHEN THEY TAKE
POWER, THOSE FIVE FORCES WILL
ALIGN AND SPEW ANTI-TRUMP
VITRIOL EVERY SECOND, EVERY
MINUTE, EVERY HOUR, EVERY DAY.
GOOD NEWS FOR THIS WILL MAKE US,
THEY WILL OVERREACH, THEY WILL
REALLY EXTEND WHAT THEY THINK IS
A MANDATE WHAT IS NOT.
WHAT THEY WANT TO, SADLY,
ANYTHING THAT WILL HELP THE
PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY.
YOU, THE PEOPLE, WE, THE PEOPLE,
AND RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THE MOST
RADICAL LEFT-WING HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES THIS HOUSE IS
EVER SEEN.
THERE ARE NO MORE MODERATES.
AND OF COURSE THE DEEP
STATESIDE, WE'VE BEEN WITNESSING
MUELLER'S DESTROYED TRUMP WHICH
WON'T PLAY OUT FOR THE PAST 558
DAYS.
BREAKING TONIGHT, HUGE NEWS,
ALLEGING THAT HIS TOP TARGET,
PAUL MANAFORT, THE TARGET WAS
ABOUT LOAN APPLICATIONS YEARS
AGO, TAX VIOLATIONS YEARS AGO.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT HE LIED TO
INVESTIGATORS AFTER AGREEING TO
HIS PLEA DEAL.
WE ALSO LEARNED THAT ROGER
STONE'S JEROME CORSI, HE HAS
REJECTED A PLEA DEAL FROM ROBERT
MUELLER.
THE DEAL INVOLVED HIM PLANING
GUILTY TO ONE COUNT OF PERJURY.
GREGG JARRETT WILL JOIN US IN A
MOMENT.
HERE'S WHAT HE NOTED, WHAT WE
ARE SEEING HERE IS THE CLASSIC
MUELLER WISEMAN TACTIC, USING
THREATS AND COERCION TO GET
PEOPLE BASICALLY TO TEST THE
LIFE, IN OTHER WORDS, WHAT THAT
USUALLY MEANS IS YOU TELL US
WHAT WE WANT YOU TO TELL US, YOU
LIVE, OR YOU ARE GOING TO GET
PUNISHED.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
IF THEY SAID WHAT MUELLER
WANTED, ALL I HAVE TO DO IS
SAYING WHAT THEY'RE BASICALLY
SAYING THEY WANT TO HEAR.
THEY WOULD LIKELY GET A BETTER
DEAL.
BY NOT DOING THIS IT MEANS BOTH
THOSE MEN KNOW THAT THEY MAY BE
RISKING SPENDING THE REST OF
THEIR LIVES IN JAIL AND THEY
HAVE DECIDED NOT TO DO IT.
THIS IS A PROFOUND DEVELOPMENT
AND I CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR THE
FULL BACK STORY IN BOTH CASES.
LOOK AT GENERAL FLYNN, 30 PLUS
YEARS SERVING HIS COUNTRY.
THE FBI DIDN'T EVEN THINK HE
LIED.
HE WAS ON THE BRINK OF
BANKRUPTCY, HAD TO SELL HIS HOME
TO PAY HIS ATTORNEYS, SO THEY
TURNED THE SCREWS, PROBABLY
THREATENED TO GO AFTER HIS OWN
SON AND NOW HE'S AWAITING
SENTENCING.
BY THE WAY, THEY DIDN'T EVEN
BELIEVE HE LIED.
THEN THERE'S GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS.
HE'S NOW IN JAIL FOR TWO WEEKS.
HE FEELS LIKE HE WAS SET UP BIG
TIME, JUST LOOK AT HIS TWEETS.
HE WILL BE LOCKED UP FOR THE
NEXT 14 DAYS, WE WILL TALK TO
HIM AFTERWARDS.
AND AS ANY OF US HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH RUSSIA COLLUSION?
NOTHING.
BECAUSE THERE IS NONE.
THERE IS NO TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
BUT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO REVEAL
ON THIS PROGRAM QUENTIN
COLLUSION.
BUT THEY CARED ABOUT COLLUSION,
THEY CERTAINLY DON'T CARE ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE IF THEY DID THEY
WOULD LOOK AT SURVEILLANCE
ABUSE, UNMASKING ABUSE, LEAKING
INTELLIGENCE ABUSE.
LYING TO FISA COURTS AND
COMMITTING FRAUD UPON THE
COURTS.
THEY WOULD LOOK AT THE CIRCULAR
LEAKS OF THE PHONY DOSSIER.
THEY WOULD LOOK AT HOW THE
DOSSIER WAS USED TO LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BEFORE THE
ELECTION AND HOW HILLARY PAID
FOR THOSE RUSSIAN LIVES, THEY
NEVER TOLD THE FISA COURT THIS.
NO ONE SEEMS TO CARE IN
MUELLER'S OFFICE.
HILLARY'S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN LIES.
THIS HAS LITERALLY BECOME THE
BIGGEST TRAVESTY OF JUSTICE, A
ONE-SIDED WITCH HUNT THAT HAS NO
INTEREST IN TRUTH OR REAL RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
HILLARY CAN PAY FOR RUSSIAN
LIES, THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY CAN PROPAGANDIZE AND LIE TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THEY DON'T
CARE.
EVEN THE AUTHOR OF THE DOSSIER,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, EVEN HE
DOESN'T STAND BY THE DOSSIER.
SO A WARNING IS BUCKLE UP
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
REHASH ALL OF IT DEMOCRATS TAKE
THE HOUSE.
WE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE LATER IN
THE PROGRAM BUT FIRST, AND JUST
MOMENTS WE WILL TAKE YOUR LIFE,
AS YOU CAN SEE, TO MISSISSIPPI,
THE PRESIDENT IS CURRENTLY ABOUT
TO RALLY VOTERS AHEAD OF THIS
IMPORTANT RUNOFF TOMORROW
BETWEEN REPUBLICAN SENATOR CINDY
HYDE-SMITH AND LIBERAL DEMOCRAT
MIKE SP.
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT RACE
THAT IS DEFINITELY IN PLAY.
IF YOU ARE IN MISSISSIPPI
BECAUSE A WIN FOR THE REPUBLICA
REPUBLICAN, THAT MEANS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE G.O.P. TO
SOLIDIFY ITS LEAD IN THE SENATE.
EITHER GOING TO BE 53-47 OR
52-48, AND REMEMBER, VOTES IN
THE SENATE ARE SO IMPORTANT,
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
THINGS LIKE CONFIRMING,
CONSTITUTIONALIST ORIGINALIST
JUSTICES, FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
MAKE IMPORTANT APPOINTMENTS LIKE
REPLACING JEFF SESSIONS AND
DEMOCRAT MIKE SP, A FAR LIBERAL
THAT CLEARLY SUPPORTS
CHUCK SCHUMER AND THE REST OF
HIS RADICAL DEMOCRATS ALREADY IN
WASHINGTON.
HE HAS BEEN DODGED BY MANY
ETHICAL QUESTIONS STEMMING FROM
HIS RECENT WORK, LOBBYING WORK
FOR AN ALLEGED WAR CRIMINAL FROM
THE WEST AFRICAN COUNTRY.
HE WAS ALSO FORCED OUT OF THE
CLINTON ADMINISTRATION BACK IN
'94 WHILE UNDER INVESTIGATION
FOR ALLEGEDLY RECEIVING IMPROPER
GIFTS.
THE INDEPENDENT COUNSEL FOUND A
PANEL OF "IMPROPER BEHAVIOR."
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA WANTS YOU TO
BELIEVE, THIS RACE IS VERY
SIMPLE, HEIGHT-SMITH IS A VOTE
FOR THE TRUMP AGENDA, THAT MEANS
CONFIRMING ORIGINALIST JUSTICES,